[Music]
and why TF elion news submitted by
Pikachu mean [ __ ] oh I've seen that
he's always like just like it started
but he's always like surprised like oh
no I wish we had Julia here well she's
not here that we don't just kidding
she's actually right behind the camera
Obama so what is the Pikachu mean she's
social media here you gotta say it real
quick go go do you know what it is she's
like I wasn't prepared to be a friend of
the camera okay surprise she doesn't
know pikachu detective movies coming out
get out of here you're supposed to know
all anime thing who's the voice of
Pikachu again was it right she knew that
she knew adds value even ideas you're
redeemed we what's crazy is Pikachu's
gonna talk that's crazy
only talking to people to him he's the
only one that can understand sounds like
Santa Paul's to me yes it's scary I
don't wanna watch it then it's a zombie
looking Santa oh [ __ ] got all these
little people that mix with children Oh
No okay what's article people describe
the weirdest lies their parents told
them as kids [ __ ] mob believe in all
that [ __ ] oh sure but it's still a lie
why don't even know my mom's real name
and I was like 15 what did you think it
was mom no I went to uh I was at Taiwan
looking through the family photo album
and then I see my mom's high school ID
and I'm like wait what that's not her
name and then I look over at my grandpa
I'm like why does it say that in your
mind he was like oh your mom didn't tell
you she changed her name after her first
divorce and I was like oh oh she was
what oh my god so I came back and I'm
like yo my 125 pound self y'all what's
up mom how come you been lied to me and
she goes oh I didn't think you're ready
for a bubble but I was like well I guess
I have to find out the hard way through
grandpa and she finally broke it all
down and told me what happened yeah for
15 years
oh so how's your mom second marriage yep
she's a townie wait which name does she
keep I don't know uh the other name wait
she was in junior high was she married
she had a different name in her high
school yeah the high school ID yeah yeah
so I don't know when she got married
maybe like 28 or whatever but it didn't
work out and so I give the Chinese
tradition it's like you want a new star
so you change your name the whole name
first name last
oh well the last thing she kept the same
but she just changed her name
I did the teeth so it's like I'm so like
all of that bad juju all that bad juju
with so after you get a divorce like
Chinese style you completely change your
name like your full first and last
year's like you're avoiding taxes no no
sure I mean I don't know if all Chinese
people did but for her because she's
really superstitious she's just like
there's a lot of bad juju maybe she
wanted just the first maybe if she maybe
if she ran into her ex she was he was
gonna be like oh hey and call her by
that name should be like I've never met
you before no here's my ID oh yeah
so her husband's like that screams not
rose what I'm candy now no she she does
she just plays at all like that
that never happened that's pretty [ __ ]
game-changer last name was she married
she's under witness protection right
yeah she kept the same okay we could
move on I'm cool to move on she knows
she was a witness to something maybe
she's under wits she has her birth last
name if that clears anything else you
should change her name when she got
married she doesn't know that Oh
that's why I was when she got married if
she change her first many way that's
what geo dead her real names Virginia no
Virginia Kelly no I think you look like
Virginia that was supposed to be
actually really yeah thank God you
didn't name me that I'm just kidding I'm
talking about okay okay all right so
these people were telling vais Serbia
their parents lives oh it's in Serbia
this is gonna be there did I vice all
over the world because they have
correspondents that right journalistic
news all over the world yeah bro we are
all over the world like a new cast in
every [ __ ] no they're not gonna be good
enough like every every hell no people
try to replicate the [ __ ] out of us they
can't do it so you do audition you do
auditions it's like hey show me how you
swing an instrument around and they're
like and it's like oh yeah right like
hey can you guys give us this news
article get it kinda wrong yeah every
five seconds yeah not good enough how do
you handle not really no yeah all right
so this first story here is titled the
toys ceiling which so this person saying
that when they were little they had this
elderly neighbor who didn't have any
teeth and she always walked around
hunched over with the scarf covering her
hair and then so yeah and then so one
day their parents said because the this
person had a lot of toys that they loved
they were really messy with them and the
parents said that they didn't pick him
up that grandmas love slow vodka which
is what they named the neighbors if she
would come and steal them and that she
had a basement that's mean why this
isn't lady from children who wouldn't
clean up their rooms and then this
person had a whole bunch of nightmares I
felt like every parent did that like
they would find some ugly weird-looking
person in Bullock I'm gonna have them
take you
yeah damn
that's me yeah they did Oh lettermen oh
really
let him come take you then it's like a
homeless guy like what I would even
watch your fault
yeah wait so I bet those kids that clean
[ __ ] rooms yeah they said that they
had neighbor of nightmares of that
person the old lady taking that's so sad
oh sweet only stuff bunny to the cold
basement and torturing it Oh ladies like
[ __ ] I just want to like love kids I
didn't mean to be a local urban legend
Jesus I like it rich like this coat yeah
but [ __ ] grandfather that murdered
his family or the or the bird lady
oh yeah there's no shovel guy sorry home
alone and the bird lady but it was one
in both because of the same [ __ ] bird
lady from Mary Poppins you remember to
hold on to you bird lady what do you men
covered in [ __ ] Birds
yeah the bench and then he runs away to
get away from the thing he goes into the
church and that's where she lives at the
top
Carver timber Wow brah remember cover
its likes freaky she got that part
exercise out of her just remember that
oh yeah I was scared of her I think you
people on set were scheduler like hey
yeah okay so we're here she did a really
good job she did this other story their
dad told them to not eat any margarine
because it was melted plastic I feel
like it kind of it's amazing like you
learned that one pretty quick you take
you you can't eat too much margin
without feeling terrible yeah he would
tell them that it was one molecule away
from plastic what's the difference
between margarine and butter butters
made from animals margins may not a
vegetable like oh okay products and
what's not I can't believe it's not that
let's [ __ ] Bob that Country Crock
[ __ ] I grew up on that I love that [ __ ]
yeah but it's super unhealthy because
your body can't break down this chemical
so he's not lying
oh you know what I think it's made out
of cotton cotton seed how do they find
this so the next one says
I'll just read it it says I was a really
hyper toddler and the only thing that
could keep me still was a TV but that
was only because my parents told me that
all the folks I watched on-screen
actually lived in their own world inside
our TV this made
watching television infinitely more
interesting but it also made me flip out
every time someone turned it off because
I was where they were killing the little
people oh you know what you [ __ ] me up
for a little bit uh they told me that if
I eat watermelon seeds the watermelons
gonna grow my stomach sounds like oh no
I said that to my niece and she was
crying learn the Rugrats and his stuff
was it cuz I was really little when I
saw it oh my gosh it's 15 my mom told me
not to swallow gum because it stays me
for nine years yeah that too yeah and
then if you salt you with gum you just
gonna have gum and your stomach you want
me to eat anything and you'll die but my
parents told me the same [ __ ] same yeah
why do they what use it's always easier
to do that to it than to explain why
does it matter like you could just
swallow gum right I mean obviously you
don't do it all day every day I like I
love this right now it's like we're all
sitting here with gum and it's like Jim
you can swallow it right like what you
can't like who's gonna do it first first
all all the juicy fruit gum that one's
worth swallowing dude bubblicious was my
favorite but then it loses flavor in
like 30 seconds yeah but the texture was
really good with the zebra ones good
that one's 10 seconds yeah what about
bazooka that's all right it's hard
exercise I like big league chew
oh yeah eat the whole bag I can taste it
every time you'll say a new brand let me
get my changes juicy fruit do they still
have bubble issues yeah
that's the tape one right is that the
tape one no it's the snow it's like a
square one but then you eat in your
breath smells even worse than before oh
wait the one that has like the little
comics on it no do you remember that
yeah of course
isn't that bazooka I think it's a good
yeah I know my god the bubble is one
vanilla candy oh that's butter fruit by
the foot
no but the gum tape yeah yeah right yeah
I forgot the name of it okay bubble tape
yeah next one it says this line actually
came from my grandma who was the person
who looked after me when I was younger I
hated milk as a child I hated the smell
and it always made me feel sick
eventually grandma got so fed up with my
whining that she decided to tell me that
my body was held together with milk and
if I stopped drinking it I would
completely disintegrate Danny I do
whatever you can Eliza's kid huh yeah
would just fall off that light turned
into a nightmare for me as I dreamed of
all walking around with no legs or teeth
I still hate milk dance like kids don't
even really need milk like well in their
head they think they do milk socks
[Music]